good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime
i'm jesse waters and in moments donald
trump jr will be joining me with
exclusive reaction
to the trump organization cfo pleading
not guilty
to those tax fraud charges today but
first
joe biden's been dismantling america
ever since he took office
we've been reporting on it extensively
yet democrats seem to believe that uncle
joe's doing a great job
until now news survey out shows even
members of the president's own party are
losing
faith in the self-described healer in
chief
since april democrats approval rating
for biden's economic agenda
plummeted 12 points and the same can be
said for just about every other issue
approving for his handling of racial
inequality taxation immigration
coveted gun violence have all dropped it
looks like they aren't buying
biden's bag of excuses for why nearly
everything in the country is falling
apart
immigration kamal is taking care of that
high taxes everybody needs to just pay
their fair share
crime get ready it's the republicans
fault you know
those republican mayors in famously
conservative cities like chicago
the gop stronghold of los angeles and
of course deep red new york city i'm
sure you remember last summer when
thousands of trump supporters marched to
the streets
chanting defund the police and black
lives matter
as they burned local businesses to the
ground but it's not just republicans
it's guns too
ignore crimes like these a postal worker
getting pummeled
by two bikers on a busy new york city
street in broad daylight
the suspects got away the mailman was
hospitalized with broken bones
i didn't see any guns there and this
shocking scene
a 35 year old woman walking down the
street in the middle of the day
gets pounced on by a sick pervert who
allegedly reached down her shorts
and groped her this is new york this is
america
and democrats are finally beginning to
wake up to what's actually
happening in their country and who's
behind it
now that his support is dropping will
joe biden finally address the problems
his party caused
joining me now republican senator from
texas ted cruz
all right senator so it only took what
less than six months people are starting
to realize
it's total disaster uh is this as long
as you thought it would take or less
well i i will say it's been dramatic
just how quickly
joe biden and kamala harris lurch to the
left i mean almost from from the opening
day of the administration
they made the decision to hand control
of the democratic party over to the
radical extreme and and so the policy
agenda
is being driven by bernie sanders and
elizabeth warren and aoc
and and we're seeing an absolute
disaster on every front you went through
on crime you know when the radicals who
advocate
abolishing the police become two of the
senior officials in the biden department
of justice
that shows they've given in to the crazy
left on the border
when you hand control of border control
policy over to the radicals who want
open borders
and don't want the laws enforced you
create a border crisis
that puts us on path to have over two
million people cross illegally
and this year and and and when you
propose seven trillion dollars in new
spending
trillions of dollars in new taxes and
new regulations that kill
small businesses and kill jobs well the
american people start to notice this and
and so the poll numbers you went through
don't surprise me at all because this
administration is lurching
radically to the left and and there's a
natural pendulum to politics
if you look in american history when one
party gets in power
often they go too far one direction and
the american people pull it back and
and i think what is happening right now
is a lot of people their eyes are
opening up and they're going wait a
second
joe biden campaigned as a moderate
reasonable guy
not as a crazy lunatic leftist and and
what we're seeing now
i think is setting us up to have a very
very good election in 2022
and an even better election in 2024 i
would agree with that
and your assessment that we are looking
at a struggling puppet
who has designated a lot of the problems
to
a vp who's not qualified to manage them
that's clear
she cackles like a wacko every time
she's asked about it
do you think though the border issue was
this by design i talked to senator
kennedy last night about this
because it seems to me more than just
rank incompetence it seems
by design i don't believe the crime
surge that they're ignoring
i don't think they want dead americans
bleeding out in the streets i don't
think they
want that i just think they're dodging
the fix because they're afraid
and it's political but the border the
border seems by design
well i don't know that the result is by
design i don't know that they envisioned
the massive surge of illegal immigration
but but the policy is by design what
what yeah
if you want to understand joe biden
kamala harris on every issue
whatever the radicals are the left-wing
radicals
biden said all right you're in charge of
those issues so on the border
it's the open border radicals who are in
charge on on
israel it's the anti-israel radicals who
are in charge on on
uh issues of of uh the so-called
equality act it's the radicals who want
to force
biological men to play in girls sports
and women's sports on every
issue it's the radicals who are driving
the agenda so i don't know that that
that joe and kamala necessarily
anticipated this crisis i think they're
just naive
they think open borders sounds wonderful
and nice and utopian
and they don't understand that when you
don't enforce the borders
that the cartels will traffic millions
of people into this country and that the
suffering will be staggering
and right now i think their hands are
tied because they've made the promises
they're not going to go back on those
promises i don't believe
so joe biden will not be willing to
enforce the border
or stop the illegal immigration so his
only solution to the border crisis
is like an ostrich stick his head in the
sand and hope that the media doesn't
cover it it's why they don't let cameras
in it's why
joe biden hasn't been to the border once
in five months in office
because he knows if he comes the tv
cameras will follow it's why
kamala harris when she finally went to
the border when she was guilted into it
she went to el paso a beautiful texas
city
that is 800 miles away from the
epicenter of this crisis in the rio
grande valley
the reason she didn't go to the rio
grande valley she didn't want tv cut
cameras covering the biden cages with
thousands upon thousands of children
packed in
in in dangerous crisis situations their
their only solution
is hide from it so they're unintelligent
and they're too stubborn to pivot to fix
the problem they started
victor davis hansen made an interesting
point last night
when you have the democrats now managing
these problems the cities
the the energy sector the border
the nuts and bolts of civilization in
the united states are starting to
crumble
so it's almost like senator you don't
really need to run in the midterms on
ideology
it's not even about ideology it's about
results
the democrats have mismanaged horribly
everything that they've put in charge of
the election in new york city they
couldn't even do that we saw
2020 we saw the iowa caucus they're just
not proficient
in what they say they're proficient in
so it's very easy for the american voter
to understand that
you have to say socialism you don't have
to say anything like that you just say
look
you're paying more here look there's
crime here people are
dying and that should be a slam dunk
case
well i i think that's right and that
there's an analog in relatively recent
history and and that's to jimmy carter
and i believe joe biden is jimmy carter
2.0 we're five months into the biden
administration
we we already have a gas crisis gas
lines an inflation crisis
war in the middle east and and the same
sort of
ideology and incompetence that
that characterized the bar the the
carter regime
characterizes now the the biden harris
regime and
and it took jimmy carter to give us
ronald reagan i think joe biden is
setting
setting up for this country to move
dramatically back in the direction of
fiscal sanity back in the direction
of the constitution and the bill of
rights yeah when you marry
incompetence with ideology it's a
disaster
every time and i'm curious now to see
who's going to be the next reagan out of
this
could be you senator you never know
thank you for joining prime time well
thank you thank you jesse appreciate it
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else